no the government has prioritized
getting the economy restarted
in the first stage of easing the
lockdown and the clock is
certainly ticking for many companies
already on the verge of going bust
to discuss this further we're joined by
the director general of the cbi
den carolyn ferb and dem fairban really
lovely to see you this morning um
how bad is it out there for your members
at the moment i think it is it is really
tough i mean we are
we have seen the furlough working well
so we got 7.5
million jobs currently protected but i
think where businesses are now is
thinking about
how we protect those jobs for the future
and
that is about a cautious careful
restart this week i think actually from
the business perspective
has been a week of glimmers of light at
the end of the tunnel
we have the encouragement at the
beginning of the week for businesses
to begin to get back to work they are
following that putting safety first
protocols
in place uh perspex staggered shifts and
so on
but what we are concerned about is that
the policies need to be coordinated
across transport across schools across
the devolved nations
and if we don't have consensus that will
undermine
confidence it will undermine confidence
amongst workers
amongst amongst the consumer as
consumers and people in general
so how we sought transport how we sought
schools
and how we get much more joined up
thinking across scotland wales northern
ireland
england is potentially a break on this
cautious restart that we now need
as you said glimmers of light for for
some of your members many
members many members many of me perhaps
many of your members
one does wonder though given this week
there has been so much talk about
whether or not the government advice has
been
straightforward whether or not it's been
confusing i i mean what are your members
telling you about the
the detail do they have the granularity
that they need
to be able to get back to work well
interestingly i think
in general the guidance has worked well
um and and it does give a level what
businesses are saying is they want
flexibility within a framework not too
prescriptive because every
business is different but clarity around
what social distancing does need to look
like
in different environments how you do
organize
lifts in in office buildings for example
and that clarity
um has come through and i think
crucially now this was done
with unions and so that is working and i
think what we now want to see
is that same kind of collaborative
approach in transporting
a lot of businesses are phoning me and
saying
actually our big worry is about how we
get our employees to work
safely what happens if they can't and
they are looking to see that kind of
collaboration so
we would like to see uh transport unions
and the government
come to an agreement that isn't where we
are now the same thing on schools we
have
many employees who are dependent on
schools being open particularly in
retail about one and a half million
non-food retail folk uh can't get back
to work unless they have
uh schools primary schools open we need
that same kind of consensus building
in other areas as well a moment ago you
mentioned
the role of transport in the transport
sector
in getting everyone back to work i
wonder what you think
of the quarantine plans as outlined by
the government perhaps
two weeks if you arrive into the united
kingdom in quadranting before you can
get out and about there
that's not necessarily going to be
helping business but then again
we've all been video conferencing all
the way through this one suspects that's
going to be carrying on for quite some
time
i have to say i think aviation getting
getting people flying again
would be an incredibly powerful boost to
our economy we're an island
economy we are service based we have
engineers who are flying in and out
of the country fixing equipment i've
been hearing from businesses in
in aerospace in manufacturing who are
really worried about
uh this potential quarantine so i think
what we would like to see
is an international standard because at
the moment you've got different
countries doing different things
uh and that is is very bad for global
trade as we were hearing
uh earlier um we do want to see a a
a real collaboration with um the
aviation sector to make
flying safe i think it is interesting
also to look at other airports around
the world we see
vienna and hong kong introducing testing
at airports as an
alternative uh to quarantine so you know
the aviation
getting people flying matters far more
than just for the aviation
sector it matters for getting our
economy open and we
do ask the economy the government to
think very carefully
about how this is introduced um so that
it doesn't put the brakes
on our economy in this fragile recovery
there was some fascinating research from
the federation of small businesses that
you may have seen this week
that one in three of uh funds that have
closed
during uh the lockdown fear that they
will
will never reopen what can be done
to help those businesses which so often
are described as the lifeblood
the backbone of our economy and yet you
know we're talking about thousands tens
of thousands of firms
believing that in the not too distant
future the chances of them reopening are
pretty much zero
i i think this is a a a huge question
and because as
i said we have we have seen the furlough
scheme protect seven and a half million
jobs
uh so far but those jobs are not safe
into the future um unless we get the
economy
growing again the furlough system the
government support schemes can't stay
in place forever so i think we need to
restart the economy very carefully and
cautiously it would be very good
to start seeing plans for the future
around infrastructure
investment investment in trading some of
the things that will
encourage businesses to think about how
they can
uh tackle new markets and and get back
on
their feet we may also need to think
about how we support those businesses
particularly smaller ones
coming out of this recession with equity
support
and possibly an additional round of
grants
but the biggest thing now is to continue
in a coordinated way
everyone joined up building trust public
trust
so that those small businesses and
larger businesses can open
safely and we can get back to growth uh
and save those jobs
what is your view and then fair about
the assertion that the government is
more interested in the health of the
economy than the health of the nation
i really think this is a false dichotomy
you cannot have a strong economy without
public safety the worst thing that could
happen would be
another lockdown these these two
objectives go hand in hand and i think
one of the things that we can draw real
encouragement from
is how businesses across the country are
making their workplaces safe i've seen
example after example from from
supermarkets now we have garden centers
manufacturers in fact 60 of the economy
has stayed open
throughout this crisis working in
partnership with our employees and
unions
to stay open we should not be seeing
these two things
in conflict we must build a consensus
going forwards about how we manage the
two together
we will be living with the virus for a
while and we mustn't have these two
uh in conflict they go hand in hand
carolyn ferban always good to talk
do stay well we'll see you again in the
program soon